you can be anything in this world that
you want to be right don't daddy teach
you that
yeah and it doesn't matter if you're
black or white or any color
critical race theory wants to end that
mobilize get together with your friends
push back because the time is now all
right so the push back to critical race
theory has begun christopher ruffo
is one of the lead researchers on that
particular issue he now works over at
the manhattan institute
and uh and he has a book out coming out
pretty soon with uh with harper
which full disclosure is also my
publisher and he's been pushing into
sort of common parliament's critical
race theory
it's been used as the term that was used
before critical race theory was woke-ism
critical race theory
is more specific because it actually
goes to the ideological roots of all of
this well
those the the root of the of the
pushback has now
created fruit and you're seeing it all
over right so you're seeing videos like
here's one that went viral
of a father and daughter a black father
and daughter pushing back against
critical race theory
it was an excellent video and the reason
it is so telling
is because because critical race theory
suggests that all the systems of america
are deeply racist and inherently
directed at promoting the subservience
of black americans particularly
it means that you're basically saying
black people they have no agency they
have no agency in america and the freest
country in the history of the world
with the richest black families on
planet earth on average
they have no agency whatsoever and so
here is a young black man named corey
yeshua and his six-year-old daughter
royalty
pushing back on critical race theory and
saying this is nonsense and it hurts
black people which it absolutely does
depriving people of agency is the worst
single thing you can do to anyone in
life
it is the worst thing when you tell
people they have no agency in their own
life you cannot do anything worse to a
child
than that truly and when you do when you
create actions
that give them no agency obviously that
is an extension of that very
idea anyway here was a corey issue this
went completely viral of course
daddy teaches you can be anything in
this world
that you want to be right don't daddy
teach you that yeah and it doesn't
matter if you're
black or white or any color doesn't
matter if you're black
white brown yellow right
black and and how we treat people is
based on who they are and not what color
they are
and if they're nice and smart see this
is how
this is how children think right here
critical race theory wants to end that
not with my children it's not gonna
happen
good for him right so this went viral
there's an illinois dad who got up
recently at a school board hearing
pushing against critical race theory
again black guy
and he said this is this is nonsense he
said color was not discussed
in my home at all
the only race it is the human race i
don't i never raised my sons to see
anybody's of color color was never even
discussed in my
house at all all we know is that as much
as children grow
they just see other kids and they'll
just immediately start playing there is
no
a child see them like why is this skin
coming like that in mind that we never
discussed that
when it all comes down to it people are
just people my sons never had to talk
about white people
by asian people all they know is that
they were people they were their friends
they played with them they never once
came home and said dad
my white friend across the street that
they just said my friends
okay and of course this is exactly right
the pushback is happening even
the mainstream media the reason that
they are starting to get so worried
about this and to lie about it
is because they are deeply deeply
worried
that the right is gonna be able to
mobilize on this because people in the
middle
right that unmotivated 60 in the middle
are looking at the left and saying what
you're preaching right now is cultic
crazy garbage that tears away every
system of freedom in the united states
and here's a pbs reporter
fully acknowledging on national tv on
sunday the critical race theory is
mobilizing people as well it should
specific to this idea of critical race
there i have to tell you just spend some
time reporting on this county in
virginia about an hour outside of
washington
and to your point this is something that
is mobilizing people and resonating very
deeply it was about a hundred degree day
dozens and dozens and dozens of parents
mostly white in this
largely affluent county showed up to a
school board meeting for many of
the very first school board meeting
they'd ever attended specifically
because of this one issue
okay as well they should the pushback
has begun again if you want to
renormalize the institutions if you want
to make them normal again
then what you're going to have to do is
stand up and say no and people in the
middle have to be aware
they are aware now they're waking up to
it and they're fighting back and this
scares the living hell out of the left
because this is the first institutional
pushback
that we have seen in america for quite
some time against a systemic
motivated left and it's great the first
thing you got to do is do what rufo has
done and others we've done it on the
show expose critical race theory for
what it is number two
tell people they have to form coalitions
with people who are in the middle and
that those coalitions have to be
mobilized against this very core
hardened group of people who are pushing
a radical ideology
and the institutions can in fact be
taken back i talk about this in my new
book
the authoritarian moment at length
because it's really really important
okay so meanwhile the media is pushing
back on all of this right and they're
telling you lies about all of this
the media have decided that they are
going to simply lie about what critical
race theory is so now because there's a
giant pushback because americans are
pushing back against critical race
theory because finally
for the first time in a very long time
you have a large swath of americans
looking
at a movement from the left that's now
been promoted across the military across
your schools
across your your universities and across
your media and in sports and in every
area of your life
because we have noticed it the media has
come up with two areas of pushback
because again they are activists
critical race theory
as the founders say of critical race
theory is not merely an idea an ideology
or philosophy it is in fact about
activism quote
critical race theory contains an
activist dimension it not only tries to
understand our social situation but to
change it
richard delgado gene stefan critical
race theory introduction right this is
their goal is to change things and many
in the media
have have drunk from the well they've
imbibed
they're infused with the spirit of
critical race theory so they've come
back with two angles of pushback
angle of pushback against the pushback
number one is
actually you just don't know
what critical race theory is and you've
seen this over and over so you saw mark
lamont hill
who is a radical idiot he had on james
lindsay
and he started explaining to him well
you know let me let me explain how this
really isn't about gramsci and you
haven't read enough gramsci and let me
explain how it's really not about
delgado or stephanie purely it's about
various other marxist thinkers and
really has nothing to do with marxism
even though everybody i'm quoting
is a marxist and everybody's like wow
that's
he he knows critical okay i just read
you the tenants of critical race theory
now you know the tenets of critical race
theory they they in their inception were
not vague they've been made deliberately
vague
the people who are criticized and then
say actually
you don't know even what you're talking
about actually you've never read
any critical race theory actually you
are just saying
something that is okay so the way this
is broadened out in the public view with
regard to the media
and you have members of the media saying
actually critical race theory is just
us teaching accurate history accurate
history is just critical race theory
okay the answer is
no it's not because critical race theory
again assumes that whiteness is
pervasive
everywhere that white supremacy is
pervasive in every institution and that
institutions and principles of power
were created in order to re-establish
and re-enshrine white supremacy okay
that's what critical race theory says
it's in its f it's founding tenets okay
but what you get is from the media is if
you push back against this
you get the coverage from the washington
post okay here's how the washington post
covers the pushback against critical
race theory quote critical race theory
holds that racism is systemic in the
united states not just a collection of
individual prejudices an idea that feels
obvious to some
and offensive to others roofo alleged
that efforts to inject awareness of
systemic racism and white privilege
which grew more popular following the
murder of george floyd by police posed
to grave threats to the nation
it's the latest cultural wedge issue
playing out largely but not exclusively
in debate over schools
at its core it pits progressives who
believe white people should be pushed to
confront systemic racism and white
privilege in america
against conservatives who see these
initiatives as painting all white people
as racist
again the way that the washington post
is boiling this down is that if you
believe
that there is racism in america then
this means that you are a critical race
theorist right and and that if you don't
believe that if you believe that there
is no racism in america you're a
conservative that of course is a great
simplification
okay this is but this is what cnn's
seller says if you're angry at critical
race theory it's just because
you don't like regular history you don't
want to be taught regular history here
goes with anderson cooper
i think that critical race theory can go
by another name uh
america's history it's amazing that
we're having this discussion where we're
celebrating juneteenth
and now individuals don't want to teach
us what led us up to juneteenth
it's as if we want to keep a secret from
our children that the founders of this
country actually own slaves
um you know at what point we'll be able
to teach children that what happened six
years ago yesterday and
charleston south carolina was a white
nationalist who walked into a church and
murdered
nine people i mean that is a part of
america's history
okay i have a question you can teach all
of those things to kids and in fact
every single school child in america
knows those things if they have been
taught history at all in every state in
america that there was slavery
in america and that many of the founders
on slave yes we all know that
because that is part of american history
in fact there was a giant
you may have missed it there was a giant
civil war where like hundreds of
thousands of americans died
over exactly this question and in fact
pretty much everybody understands that a
white nationalist shot up a black church
in south carolina because we're all
alive when that happened
but the basic idea here is that if you
don't push the idea that every
institution in america is rife with
racism and you as a white person don't
properly understand racism
this means that you're just not studying
regular history you get the same thing
from the washington post jonathan k part
i hear he was saying the same thing
people are trying to stop us from
learning history so this is misdirect
number one is that if you hate racial
critical if you hate critical race
theory because it's garbage
the real thing you're trying to do is
stop people from learning history it's a
lie
the people who are trying to you know
pushing back against quote-unquote
critical race theory which is basically
a blanket way of keeping us from
recognizing talking about and teaching
the fullness of our history what they're
doing is
they're denying the country it's full
it's full retelling
the united states is a is a great nation
and even though people are trying to
keep
us from learning our all of our history
miss oppali showed that it is possible
to do things to make it possible so that
the generations coming and the
generations unborn get to know their
entire history warts and all okay this
is misdirect number one is the critical
race theory it's just history no it's
not the people who
literally the people who wrote critical
race theory say it's not just that
right they say that brown versus board
of education for example is a racist
decision
designed to uphold white supremacy okay
that's what critical race theorist derek
bell says
and that's not teaching history that's
teaching garbage okay so that's
misdirect number one is that if you
don't like critical race theory the push
back to the pushback
you don't like critical race theories
because you don't want to study history
then there's pushback number two
pushback number two is that critical
race theory doesn't exist poof
it's in your imagination and if you've
noticed that all the theories of
critical race theory have been
entered into education and if you've
noticed that there are educational
departments that explicitly say
critical race theory is taught if you
noticed that they're they're actual
military departments that talk openly
about critical race theory if you've
noticed that robin deangelo is getting
hired by your corporation or urban x
candy
is being pushed by your corporation or
that on your recommended book
list from your toothbrush company is
ibrmx kenny if you've noticed any of
this
it's because you're crazy it's all in
your imagination
so chuck todd again this is you cannot
trust your media because they lie to you
because they are part of this
institutional push
here is chuck todd from msnbc saying
critical race theory this is all
creation it's just a creation
let's take this uh this so-called
controversy over critical race theory
and i say so-called controversy because
it's sort of
it's a creation that keeps people
watching or keeps people clicking
and suddenly you know yada yada school
board meetings are getting disrupted
right
and you're just sort of like wait a
minute are you covering the news that
people need to know
yes we are you're not you're downplaying
it
basically pretending that none of this
exists of course it exists
it exists in schools we have private
schools teaching we have public schools
teaching it
and your job as the media is to expose
that and you say well that's not
newsworthy you know it's newsworthy
whatever donald trump ate and crapped
out today that's newsworthy
what's truly newsworthy is a theory
we'll go for four years on donald trump
as a russian catspaw but we won't spend
30 seconds
on most school boards in major
metropolitan areas of the united states
have taken up the rubric of anti-racism
which is really just a renaming
of critical race theory that we won't
pay any attention to okay chris hayes
does the same thing on msnbc
he tries to blame the right for even
reacting to critical race theory in the
first place
he had a chiron the other day on msnbc
that is so beyond crazy it's like
he said that the right is fixated on
race we're fixated on race that's all
you guys care about
it's literally all you guys talk about
like 24 hours a day
and when we notice when we push back
then it's oh i can't believe they
noticed
i mean like really look at these people
obsessed with the race here's chris
hayes doing this routine
critical race theory uh as a sort of
technical term is
basically a set of analytic tools that
academics in some fields use starting in
law
for studying systematic racism in our
society the right has rendered the term
meaningless through over deployment
making it into a culture war rallying
cry
since february month over month the
mentions of the term have more
than doubled entire right-wing media
machinery has become obsessed
whipping up a moral panic almost
entirely among white people that
their children are being taught toxic
truths about america's long history of
racial oppression hierarchy
okay it's amazing right oh my god
they're mentioning critical race theory
yes we noticed
you mentioned it and we noticed so the
gas lighting is on two levels one is
it's just history no it's not
it's an actual theory that was meant to
be an active theory according to his
founders
second the lie is that it doesn't exist
it absolutely does exist and it has a
cost
and the cost is that we are not allowed
anymore
according critical race theory to call
out problems as we see them in the
united states whether they are problems
of actual racism
or whether they are problems that are
not due to racism but result
in an unequal outcome because it turns
out that if you want to prevent unequal
outcome if you would like more equal
outcome
people have to act differently but if
you notice that people have to act
differently
for example you say that crime should be
policed right you should actually spend
time policing crime
rather than suggesting that the cops are
racist this is because you have not
imbibed
from the well of critical race theory
you have not recognized your own white
supremacy you've not recognized that the
police are in fact a tool of white
supremacy
in the united states and the costs of
this are largely borne by black
americans
not entirely but largely born by black
yet the same people who are pushing
critical race theory are pushing defund
the police because they believe that the
police
are in the words of nicole hannah jones
basically the errors to the slave
catchers
and so is it any wonder that you see
kids being caught in crossfire
in the bronx here we have video of kids
being caught in a crossfire in the
middle of new york city
okay this wouldn't have happened even 10
years ago in new york city
when you drink deep from critical race
theory what you end up is with is more
suffering
more inequality more cruelty
more violence and apparently more happy
members of the media
and and the the pushback has begun it
should begin and uh frankly i'm ecstatic
to see
how far the pushback is going at this
point again mobilize get together with
your friends
push back because the time is now the
battle for the culture is heating up we
here at the daily wire are making some
big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment